[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELISSE ROCHE: Hello, and
welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google
Cloud, hosted every Tuesday.
My name is Elisse Roche.
And I'm on the data
and analytics marketing
team, working around social
environmental impact.
So I'm especially
pleased to welcome you
all to a special session
that we're hosting today
in light of Earth Day.
We have with us Linda
Mallers, the CEO and founder
of FarmLogix here to share her
story about her organization,
what inspired her
to start it, and how
she implemented GCP solutions
in order to scale her business.
As a heads up, we'll be
taking live questions
throughout the webinar.
So feel free to
submit them online.
We have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
And we'll also be
hosting a live Q&A
at the end of our presentation.
So with that, let's get started.
So before we dive
into the amazing work
that Linda and FarmLogix
has done to date,
I thought it would be
interesting to rewind a bit
and share a brief
history on Earth Day.
So Earth Day began with
an ecological tragedy.
In 1969, over three
million gallons of oil
spilled off the coast
of Santa Barbara,
killing over 10,000 animals
in the region, from sea lions
to dolphins to
seagulls, among others.
Now, by that point, America
had been somewhat primed
for a new ecological
consciousness with the 1962
publication of Rachel
Carson's "A Silent Spring."
It was in that work that she
discussed the impact of DDT
and other pesticides
on the environment
on all living things, from
crops to the pests that
afflicted those crops to
ecological systems, animals,
and humans.
Now, at that point, the US
Senator Gaylord Nelson actually
decided to mobilize on that
new ecological consciousness,
and coming off of the
movements of the 1960s.
And so in 1969, in light
of that ecological tragedy
in Santa Barbara, he proposed
a televised national teach-in
on the environment, which
took place on April 22nd.
Millions of Americans
rallied that day
to support new responsible
environmental practices,
leading to the
creation of the EPA,
and also clean acts later
enacted by Congress.
From there, it grew
into a global movement.
So fast forward 40 plus years
to the new and ever-growing
challenges that we face with
the environment, one of which
is the concept and the
opportunity of sustainability,
at which food is at the
heart of the matter.
Industrial food systems
are the common denominator.
They sit, essentially,
as a common denominator
across a variety of factors
that actually directly
drive or contribute
to climate change.
To name a few, there are
carbon emissions, pesticides
and pollution, deforestation,
and also water supply.
And here's a taste
of what's at stake.
One third of all
human-caused greenhouse
gas emissions is caused
by the global food system.
And agricultural practices
are responsible for around 74%
of greenhouse gas nitrous
oxide in the United States.
Now, what that does
is that actually
contributes to the rising global
temperatures across the world.
With respect to
pesticides and pollution,
agriculture is the
largest contributor
of ammonia pollution and
other nitrogen compounds,
which compromises
our air quality.
And pesticides
can be transported
in runoff and
groundwater and can
result in toxic levels
for humans and wildlife,
which then compromises
our water supply.
And with respect
to deforestation,
75% of global deforestation
is caused by agriculture.
And that's especially
problematic,
given the stats they shared
around carbon emissions.
Here we are, emitting even more
emissions into the atmosphere
and depleting the
natural resources that
act as a counterbalance--
the carbon stores, also known
as trees.
Since 1960, one third of
the world's arable land
has been lost through erosion
and other land degradations.
And with respect to water
supply, to support agriculture,
rates of groundwater
withdrawal are
increasing relative to
water source replenishment
in the United States.
That is, we are taking
more water from the Earth
than the Earth can
actually replenish.
And by 2025, 1.8
billion people are
expected to live with
absolute water scarcity.
Now, that does not just
impact agriculture or food.
That impacts our
potential for life,
as water is crucial to life.
So with all that
being said, where
does FarmLogix come into play?
They're continuing the
legacy of Earth Day
by fostering these new
responsible environmental
practices.
They're changing
the way that we eat
and they're also
supporting local farmers.
And that all begins
with the story of Linda.
At age 40, she discovered
the thrill of the outdoors
and the beauty of nature.
She was selected to
join the USA triathlon
team for her age group and
began racing across the country.
It was on these well-worn
paths with the sun beating down
upon her back that she had the
opportunity to meet farmers,
to hear their stories,
to hear their strife
and their struggle,
their inherent desire
to live a green
and healthy life,
and also be compensated fairly
for the work that they do.
She made an instant connection.
And it was from that
point that she, in 2012,
later on, actually
founded FarmLogix,
naturally at her kitchen table,
a place of community, family,
storytelling, and nourishment.
She applied her experience
in the futures industry
developing technology platforms
to the agricultural system
in order to build and scale
sustainable supply chains.
Just one year later,
FarmLogix became
the farm-to-school solution for
Aramark Chicago Public Schools
and over 2,000
locations, overseeing
the sourcing of over $20
million worth of local foods.
Now, today, FarmLogix provides
food technology services
nationwide with an eye towards
corporate responsibility,
and actually offers
auditing services.
They also manage active
procurement in over 15 states,
and maintain an
e-commerce platform
for buyers and sellers.
Now, these are all bullet
points in a timeline.
But there is a narrative arc
that unites all of the above.
And that is a story revolution.
That is a story of change
and a story of impact.
That is a story around not only
changing the way that we eat
and empowering local farmers
through integrated cloud
computing solutions
provided by GCP,
but also bridging an
increasingly large gap
between people and food,
between people and nature,
and between people
and our home--
that is, the Earth.
And that is truly in
the spirit of Earth Day.
So with all that
being said, I would
like to welcome Linda to
begin her presentation.
LINDA MALLERS: Hi.
Thank you so much, Elisse.
And thank you so much,
Google, for having me here
to tell our story.
This is what a sustainable
supply chain looks like.
But before I get
into the details,
I want to go back and tell
you a little bit about racing
and the connection
with the farmers.
Some of the racing that I did
was called adventure racing,
where you race in
wilderness locations
with nothing but a pack on
your back for 48 to 72 hours.
And you are in mother nature,
big, with all its glory
and all its challenges.
But at the end of the day, I was
able to go home, put my racing
clothes away, take a shower,
and sign up for my next race.
I learned through meeting
the farmers along the way
that farmers don't
have that opportunity.
They are faced with the power of
mother nature every single day.
So drought or rains or bounty
or not, that is their struggle.
And that is something that
I related to very much.
I found, really,
how disconnected
we had become from
our food system.
We-- and myself included--
have really lost our connection
that there are many who
actually grow our food.
And I realized that
they are our heroes.
And I wanted to help them.
And that is how
FarmLogix came to be.
I started out as a CSA
from my kitchen table.
And it developed into this
chart that you can see now.
Basically, when local food was--
this is actually a real chart
about how farm to fork works
at Chicago Public Schools,
Aramark Chicago Public
Schools, which is one
of the largest school
districts in the country.
And they have the largest
farm-to-school program
that we run.
And basically, when
we came on board--
you'll see that they have
four distributors there
on the chart.
Each one of those distributors
was told, perhaps,
to source a local apple.
And in doing that, they
would source from a state,
perhaps, maybe
from several farms.
But basically, you had four
different sources going out
and looking for that food.
And a lot of the data
ended up getting lost.
And we realized that.
And it was really hard
for Chicago Public Schools
to be able to tell
any sort of story.
So what we did was we created
a technology platform--
we call it Aggrega8--
that allows farmers to post
their availability online
so that large institutions,
like Chicago Public Schools,
can see what local
food is available
and actually order it.
I put a red box around
logistics aggregation,
because that's the
role that we play.
We come in there
and basically allow
the schools, universities,
health care systems, business
dining, such as maybe
your cafeteria here,
and sports venues to be able to
all order from the same farm.
But we turn around and place
a single order with that farm.
The technology places
a single order.
So to the farmer, they know
they've sold an entire trailer
truck of apples.
They may not know exactly
who's buying from them.
But that's OK.
We're really helping
them stay on the farm
and helping future
generations stay on the farm.
We then turn around, and the
technology sells that product
to the distributors.
So the distributors
have just one customer,
which is FarmLogix
technology platform,
and managed by our
technology platform.
And really, what that does
is it keeps the distributor
from having to manage multiple
small farm relationships, which
is very complex, and was
hindering the movement.
So we kind of sat
there in the middle.
We call it Aggrega8.
And Aggrega8 really
streamlines the whole process.
From there, we do
our data collection,
which is the chart that you
see here, and run metrics.
And those metrics are run
nationally and by location.
And they're used by the
government, food service
companies, distributors,
really to figure out
where is this food going,
and what is selling?
And that really
helps the farmers
determine what to plant.
On the far right, you'll
see this is a single day's
serving of carrots.
It comes from Will
Allen's Growing Power
in Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
36,000 pounds-- that
is one day's lunch.
And it feeds 350,000
kids at 650 schools.
So really, to grow
the local food system,
you really have to think about
scale and meaningful impact.
And this is how
we make it happen.
So basically, responsible
sourcing at scale
requires equitable
access to healthy foods.
So we eventually, as
we started to scale,
went beyond the farm-to-school,
and started bringing that food
into the home.
And so last year, we actually
won a grant as a team
with the Chicago Community Trust
and the Kinship Foundation.
It was called the
Food-to-Market Challenge.
And it was to create a CSA where
Chicago Public Schools were
actually pickup
locations for food that
could be brought into the
home and not just enjoyed
at lunch at school.
We now have several schools
as pickup locations,
and we've expanded that
into the health care sector.
And we have, now, five
hospitals in Chicago
that are pickup locations.
And we also work with
a retailer, Peapod.
And we work with them
in multiple markets
running a CSA for them that's
everything is farm identified.
So consumers can
order a CSA online,
and have it delivered to their
home to support local farms.
We also have
farm-to-school, -campus,
and -workplace
programs that basically
allow people to enjoy local
foods when they're away
from home.
Our consumer custom
e-commerce technology
reestablishes the fact
that we have a choice.
I think what started to happen
when big ag came and we started
to scale for global
production, we lost our choice.
And we started being told
what we were going to eat
and what was available.
And I think, beginning
with Earth Day,
and then eventually, the
rise of the farmer's markets,
consumers realized they
really had a choice.
And if they used
their voice, they
could have access to
healthy food away from home.
And so really, our e-commerce
technology provides choice
and acknowledges that
the consumer has--
there's incredible
variations, like a thumbprint,
in what one considers
local and sustainable.
And our e-commerce
allows you to shop
by what's important to you.
And everything we do is
fully transparent at the time
of order.
We provide farm profiles,
videos, and full source
transparency for storytelling.
This is an example of an online
program that we run for Peapod.
As you can see, it's
called The Local Farm Box.
On the lower right is
an example of the box.
We also run other programs with
other products, such as meats.
Everything comes with a recipe
and farm profiles as well.
And then we provide, again,
the metrics on everything.
So you're looking at not
just produce and organics.
You're looking at sustainable
and humanely-raised meats.
You're looking at organic
dairy, cage-free eggs, bakery,
and other responsibly
sourced products.
So we basically have three
aspects to our technology.
We started out with e-commerce.
And then we launched
Open Fields in 2017.
Open Fields basically
takes $6 billion
worth of purchasing data.
And we scrubbed it by 85
sustainable attributes.
So those attributes
run into categories
such as ecologically sound, fair
trade, human health, locally
sourced, and even seafood.
And basically, what we do is we
provide this custom searching
experience through Open Fields.
So somebody can go
online and say, show me
what is 15 miles from
me that is organic.
Show me humanely raised
meats within my state.
We have custom definitions of
local by mileage radius, state,
combinations of state
or even state programs.
We also provide compliance
with sustainability programs,
such as AASHE STARS,
which is the American
Association for Sustainability
in Higher Ed, Real Food
Challenge, and Health
Care Without Harm.
And these programs have
requirements and auditing
that is required.
And so our search
tool allows you
to search for compliant
products for those programs.
And just a plug for Google
here-- at the bottom,
you'll see that, in
our platform, also,
is the ability to generate
Google Maps to show
the location of the farm.
And it also displays the
mileage to the location
of the person searching.
So if you think
of Open Fields, is
we consider Open
Fields the possible.
And the possible
is really what's
out there that's available to
purchase but has not been--
well, has been purchased
by someone else,
but not nationally purchased
by the person searching.
Open Fields reporting is
a post-transaction product
that we have that
allows any location that
uses our services to
be able to run metrics
on their sustainable purchasing.
Often, you'll find a
distributor or a company that
is selling a product,
will provide reporting,
but when you really
think about it,
somebody like the
University of Virginia,
which is highlighted here, will
use 20, 30 different sources.
So to get that whole
holistic reporting,
you really need to
do data collection
from all your purchasing.
So we basically take
that data collection,
and then we provide our
clients with a dashboard
from which they can tell
their sustainable story.
And again, just like you can
search by custom metrics,
you can run your reports by
customer metrics as well.
So this is basically
a STARS report
for the University of Virginia,
all their locations, all
their purchasing.
And one thing to note
is that since there
is no single definition
for responsible sourcing
in the food space, these reports
can be run multiple times
for multiple reasons.
Some people might want to
run a full sustainability
report and a STARS report.
And we provide that
complete flexibility.
We also can offer the ability
to do very large scale metrics--
oops-- metrics across an entire
enterprise, the entire country,
et cetera.
Aggrega8 is our
e-commerce platform.
You had looked at the
flow chart for that.
And so Aggrega8, this is what
it looks like when a purchase is
actually happening.
An institution would
go online to place,
let's say, the apples
that you see on the left.
The buyer would see the
price, the pack size, which
is important to institutions.
Things are sold in 20
pound cases, usually.
They would see the farm
that is growing the product.
They would see the
miles to their location
to see if it complies with
their definition of local.
If you look at the top,
you will see that there
are tabs for days of the week.
What we do is we use this as
an advanced ordering system,
where multiple,
multiple institutions--
60, 70, perhaps-- in a region
will go online and order
by the week a month in advance.
And then what we do is we
add up all of that demand
and give a single
order to a farm
with what they need to
have available each week.
And then basically, on the
other side of Aggrega8,
distributors are made aware of
when the product is coming in
and when the customer
is expecting it.
Believe it or not,
Aggrega8 is a tool
that is being used now
by the nonprofit world.
We just formed a collaboration
with the National Farm
to School Network, and we'll
be launching a pilot in June
in Illinois.
And basically,
what will happen is
we will be using our reporting
tools to gather information
on their farm-to-school
activity in Illinois.
And then we will
identify common products
that all school
districts are buying,
and create an Aggrega8
platform for them
to scale the farm-to-school
movement in Illinois
through the use of Aggrega8.
So we're very
excited about that.
Behind the scenes
in Aggrega8, are
tools for farms to become
food safety compliant.
One thing to-- the
law is the law,
and the Food Safety
Modernization Act
requires farms and will require
farms, regardless of size,
to be able to comply
with food safety.
So basically, they will have
to say when they harvested
their product, the date
that they packed it,
who picked it up,
when it was delivered,
and then what
source it came from.
And that could be a
farm or even a field.
So Aggrega8 provides
this behind-the-scenes
for the farmer.
We provide it free to any
farmer that works in our system,
basically.
But also, food hubs
and cooperatives
can use it to manage their
own business, almost as
a small ERP system.
Basically, then, from that
data, labels can be generated.
And those labels then
can be put on the boxes
with barcodes for
full compliance
with large distributors.
So basically, we allow
that small farmer
to play in a much bigger
space by providing them
with the food safety.
And this is super important.
There was actually
a, as you know,
last week, an E. coli break out.
And it's interesting.
They've identified where that
Romaine lettuce actually grew.
But I think you can
tell that it was
a very large grower,
because there
were outbreaks in 11 states.
That tells you that that's a
large grower, when that product
is getting into 11 states.
So when you do purchase
locally, and you
know where that
food is coming from,
you get a label like
this on your box.
And it's just a much
more contained issue.
So that's another reason
to purchase local.
And then just bigger
picture, all of this activity
gets entered into our
database, obviously.
Again, more than $1 billion
of sustainable transactions
have run through our system.
And that continues to grow.
But we're able to turn
around and deliver metrics
to large food service management
companies, distributors,
nonprofits, and the
government as well.
And we do that by a
variety of metrics
that you can see on the screen--
location, farm, SKU, spend,
fruit category, and product.
So just real quickly, I'll
talk about the timeline,
because we're going to get
into the tech a little bit now.
In 2013-14, I
personally launched this
at my kitchen table using
three off-the-shelf tools.
And I called myself
Oz behind the curtain,
because it looked great,
but it was a lot of work.
And then in 2014, we started
to create a proprietary program
in MySQL.
And we launched
our four products--
CloudSlot, Open Fields,
Aggrega8, and MaetaData.
And that's not a misspelling.
That was my grandmother's name.
In 2017, we migrated to Google
BigQuery for our reporting
platform, and are currently
operating on multiple clouds.
In 2018, we have
plans to integrate
to Google Cloud SQL and API.
And then in 2019, we have plans
to integrate to Elasticsearch
and add Google Retail Solutions.
So a little bit
about how that looks.
Right now, you'll see the MY
SQL on the upper left in the AWS
environment.
Nightly now, we
export that data.
That goes to the
Google Cloud Server
and down into
BigQuery, where we do
manual file exports of large
size for enterprise metrics.
And then we use Jasper Soft and
Power BI for individual metrics
and reports that you saw,
similar to the University
of Virginia.
Currently, we're using
Algolia for our search engine
and Jasper Soft
for our reporting,
in addition to
Microsoft Power BI.
And we were one of your first
beta customers for BigQuery
to Microsoft Power BI.
And by the way, we use
the consulting firm
Aptitive in Chicago to do this.
This was their recommendation,
to move to BigQuery,
and we're really appreciative.
They did a great job.
OK.
So 2018 sees us starting
to migrate from MySQL.
And so we will be doing
that, and we're actually
doing that currently,
to Google Cloud Server.
And what that's going
to allow us to do
is really scale our business.
MySQL was really never
meant to run $6 billion
worth of purchasing data.
It really was meant to build
an e-commerce platform.
And we didn't really
see this direction
when we launched the company.
So Google Cloud SQL is going to
be able to allow us to scale.
And then that data
will go into BigQuery,
and also go into our
Aggrega8 commerce system.
So we're really
excited about that.
The next thing, number two,
that you can see on the chart
is we also are going to start
accepting contributed data.
And that would be
purchasing data
from outside sources,
small vendors that
don't make it into
the system, farmers
that have product to sell.
So we basically
are transitioning
to a full true marketplace.
2019, you see us
also transitioning
to Google Elasticsearch,
which would possibly
replace Algolia for us so that
there's more full integration.
We'll probably also
use your Kibana tool,
and then also transition to
using Google Cloud and BigQuery
for our e-commerce
as well, which would
be a whole environment for us.
And the idea of that
is very, very exciting.
So why did we choose
Google Cloud Platform?
Well, Aptitive chose
it for us first.
But why do we love it?
The open platform
integrates seamlessly
with our MySQL database.
So there were no issues
making a transition.
The migration was
quick and easy.
We started in late November, and
we were done by the holidays.
So it was wonderful.
It was about 30 days.
And we had complete
visibility that
was not possible with MySQL.
The dataprep is intuitive
and transparent.
And there's many of us
that access and use it.
BigQuery is compatible with
a wide variety of reporting
solutions that we're
beginning to experiment with,
which is exciting.
The flexible structure allows us
to grow when the time is right.
The managed services
and security
allow us to grow faster than
our learning curve sometimes.
And Elasticsearch
and Retail allows
us to run our apps
from a single database.
So just at a glance,
obviously, technology
scales all sorts of things.
But in our space, what
is really exciting
is that it's scaling a movement.
It's scaling a
true movement to be
able to put together
and scale and really
have impact, not
just on local farms,
but equal access
to healthy foods
in all neighborhoods
in rural neighborhoods,
urban neighborhoods.
We all go to restaurants and
eat local food on the menu.
But it's exciting to us
when we see that food moving
into low income
communities, communities
that don't have
grocery stores, when
you see people having access to
healthy food and their health
improving.
So basically, what
Google is doing
for us is allowing us
to scale a movement.
And so we see technology
as a tool in that regard,
and we're very grateful.
Just some stats on us--
we've saved 1,500 metric
tons of CO2 since inception.
And our technology
allows buyers to source
by custom mileage parameters.
Small farms producing for fruits
and vegetables consumption
usually don't use
harmful pesticides.
That is usually used to
grow food not for humans.
So the small
farmers that you see
on the roadside at your
farmer's market usually
don't use those pesticides.
And so our system now
identifies 12 criteria
for ecologically sound,
certified organic foods,
et cetera, that support
these small farms.
One thing that's
super important is
that the rise of
superbugs in this country
is due to the antibiotic
resistance compounded
by the antibiotics that
we eat in our food.
It isn't because we have
taken too many antibiotics.
It's because we eat
too many antibiotics.
And there are a lot of poultry
producers and pork producers
who are now realizing this,
and really transitioning--
and we commend them--
to being fully no
antibiotic ever.
It's actually called NAE.
And our system identifies
products that are NAE.
And we actually
run an NAE program
through Chicago Public Schools.
And then the average age of
the American farmer is 58.
And what we really want is
we want the next generation
to want to stay on the farm.
We want farming to be
a viable occupation.
We want there to be abundance.
And we want there to be hope.
And so really, that
is why we're here.
And basically, what our
farm-to-school programs,
our farm-to-cafeteria programs,
our CSA programs, really are
create that real scalable
model for the future
so that we all thrive.
ELISSE ROCHE: And that's a wrap.
Well, thank you, Linda.
So before we dive
into the Q&A, I've
have actually prepared a few
questions myself for Linda.
So to start, how would
you define local?
And how does that
definition come into play
when serving communities
around the United States?
LINDA MALLERS: Yeah.
Well, my personal
definition really
doesn't matter, because local
is in the eye of the beholder.
So for some people,
it might be what's
down the road, what's within
50 miles of me, what's
in my state, what's in
the states touching me.
And that's actually
somebody's definition.
The state of Rhode
Island's definition
is the state of Rhode Island.
So really, what we do is we
allow folks to both search
and purchase by what
their definition is,
and then for the
reporting and metrics
to be run by what our
clients' definition is.
For instance, Aramark's
definition is 250.
But a lot of their clients,
it's not their definition.
And so we really allow for
that custom definition.
Yeah.
ELISSE ROCHE: That's great.
And originally, you
started out by creating
sustainable and
local food systems.
Now, you collect
national scale food data.
How does that data drive
consumer decisions?
LINDA MALLERS:
Well, I think what's
really interesting about our
database is that we did not
realize, when we started
collecting this data,
that there's a lot that
the consumer is buying
that's already local
and sustainable
and they didn't know it.
So I think what's happening
is it's exciting for people
to see, oh, I didn't
realize that that
was grown in Michigan.
I didn't realize that that
chicken that I'm eating
has no antibiotics in it.
And so really,
what we're doing is
we're creating
opportunities for education.
And an educated consumer
will drive the movement.
ELISSE ROCHE: Yeah.
And in today's
complicated food system,
how can the average
person drive change?
How can someone
navigate the variety
of labels and classifications
to make more environmentally
conscious choices?
LINDA MALLERS: Well, I'd
say that, obviously, there's
a lot of labeling that we see.
And there's a lot of labeling
we see that isn't true.
And so I think that there's
legislation being done by that,
and that's very,
very important work.
But as consumers, I think what
we have to do is use our voice.
ELISSE ROCHE: Yeah.
LINDA MALLERS: I think that
what's really interesting
is we see the loudest voices
on college campuses today.
And really, what's
happening is, rather than
demand local food
on a menu, they
are demanding it
everywhere they go.
They want it on
their college campus.
They want it in their dorms.
Eventually, when they
go out into the world,
they want it at work.
And you see people,
even health care--
people wanting to
make food choices
when they're in the
hospital, anywhere they are.
And so I think that what we
can do is keep using our voice,
because everybody's individual
voice is getting pretty darn
loud.
Yeah.
ELISSE ROCHE: That's awesome.
And looking ahead to 2030, at
the 17 Sustainable Development
Goals developed by the UN,
sustainable food systems
are necessary to achieve
those goals, like zero hunger
and responsible consumption.
What would you say are
critical practices that
must be continued or adopted
in order to reach those goals?
LINDA MALLERS:
Well, I think what's
really important is to recognize
the entire supply chain needs
to be involved.
I was reading those
goals this morning.
And in order to eradicate
poverty and hunger and these
very large issues that
we have-- disease--
you really have to engage
the whole supply chain.
And we have to work together,
and we have to collaborate.
Nobody can be thrown
under the bus.
Often, we see large
companies in this space
being thrown under the bus
just for being large companies.
But it's large institutional
buyers and large distributors
that have the ability and the
customers to buy this food
and move this food.
And so we all have
to play together.
And that's how we
see real change.
Yeah.
ELISSE ROCHE: Absolutely.
Well, that is certainly
an inspiring vision
for the future.
And now, with that, I would like
to thank you again, and move
to the live Q&A. We'll be
back in less than a minute.
So now, we have some
questions from the audience.
To start, what was the
initial prototyping process
like for Aggrega8?
LINDA MALLERS: It makes me
laugh reading that question.
That was five years ago.
So basically, we used just
an off-the-shelf e-commerce
platform called Volusion.
You can go to volusion.com.
We still operate
some of those today.
And basically, but it
was really interesting,
because typical e-commerce
cannot sustain the growth,
mostly because you look
at pictures of product,
and a lot of people buying in
the institutional space want
to look at lists.
So then we developed a
list on another platform,
and then we would move
that data over to Volusion.
And I'm telling you,
it was very funny.
So I would say that it
began with very, very
basic e-commerce.
And then what we
really did is we
waited until we knew where
all the supply chain gaps were
and what existed
out there before we
created our own platform.
But that was what
the prototyping was.
It was barely.
ELISSE ROCHE: You've
come a long way.
LINDA MALLERS: Yeah.
ELISSE ROCHE: And
second question
is what's the greatest issue
facing farmers today that you
think technology can solve?
LINDA MALLERS: Well, it depends
on which issue they face.
There are tons of tech
solutions out there
in the growing
space to help them--
I actually just read
an article about you
all, that Google was
doing some research
on being able to alert farmers
of future weather issues
that might impact them
and how they can protect
themselves, which is terrific.
So we see a lot
of tech solutions
on the growing side to help
protect farmers and help
them scale, help them harvest
more efficiently, et cetera.
I think that the space we occupy
and where we think we help--
and there's not that
much participation there
on the technology
side right now--
is in bringing their
products to market.
We're a firm
believer that farmers
need to focus on growing.
That's what they're great at.
And we like to have
our technology take
care of the rest.
ELISSE ROCHE: And
the last question
that we have from the audience
is what are FarmLogix's most
important metrics and KPIs?
LINDA MALLERS: Well, I
would say, you know what?
Again, it's in the
eye of the beholder
and what they want to report on.
But I would say I think
what's most important is when
we create that baseline
for a customer,
when we're in the corporate
responsibility space
working on a project, where we
develop that baseline and say,
here's where you are today,
and where do you want to be?
And then we help them not
only measure but also identify
where there are gaps and
rooms for improvement.
And so some of that
is going to be maybe
you should change your
seafood purchasing practices,
or obviously, produce is less
expensive than sustainable
meats.
And so maybe you want to add
some of that into the mix.
And so really, the metrics
are the baseline, and then
the goal and the achievement.
ELISSE ROCHE: That's great.
Well, those are
all the questions
that we have from the audience.
We'd like to thank Linda
again for joining us today
in our special session
today on Earth Day.
So thank you again.
And stay tuned for more Cloud
OnAir Webinars coming your way
every Tuesday.
[MUSIC PLAYING]